Sankt Stephan, Sankt Stephan, Sankt Stephan ist ein toller Mensch, er lehrte uns das Teilen und ein grosser Streit war abgetan, auf ewig sei ihm Dank. Toll habt ihr das gesungen, richtig toll. Es geht besser, ich sag ganz klar. Nein, das war super. Jetzt seid doch nicht immer so kritisch mit den netten Kindern hier. Wie geil ist das? Ja, das ist doch dafür lebe ich. So, und jetzt du Vatikan. Ich will doch nicht viel. Ich will doch nur ein Götterkult um mich herum. Ja, das kriegst du doch. Das hast du dir doch verdient, Stefan. Mehr will ich doch gar. Ich hab mich noch nie so gefreut. Ja, das ist natürlich sehr, sehr schön. Vielen Dank. Da hat sich jeder von euch fünf Euro verdient. Oder da gab es eine lange Diskussion, ob man Kindern Geld geben soll für ihre Arbeit, was legal ist oder nicht vielleicht eine Erdnuss. So oder so, danke Linus für deinen Besuch. Aber bezahlt man die nicht auch in Erdnüssen? Bezahlt man die nicht auch in Erdnüssen? Affen werden in Erdnüssen bezahlt, ja. Erstmal, wer war das denn jetzt genau? Linus, vielen Dank an Linus. Aber Linus hat gezeichnet, und am Ende interessiert es auch niemanden mehr, wer da noch dabei war. Also Linus hat jetzt nicht die anderen krediten wollen. Nein. Okay, ich habe viele tolle Texte gelesen, Sankt-Stefan-Texte, die ihr geschrieben habt, habe ich alle mit großer Freude gelesen. Das kann ich mir vorstellen, ja. Hast du Kritik, hast du Feedback? Nein. Also du als Heiliger musst ja immer noch mal drüber lesen, über alle Texte, die für dich geschrieben wurden. Falls ihr es nicht mitbekommen hat, Stefan hat ein Wunder gewirkt. Stefan hat zwei. Mein erstes. Ja, weil wir brauchen ja zwei Wunder. Und er ist noch ganz aufgeregt. Er ist noch ganz hinderlich. Weil ich brauche ja noch eins, deswegen bin ich so aufgeregt, das ist noch nicht abgeschlossen. Stefan, du bist jung und du hast schon eins auf dem Buckel, du hast schon eins im Köcher, eins ist safe. Ja, aber ich habe es so lange dafür gebraucht und ich kann mir es nicht leisten, nach dem Tod des Heiligen gesprochen zu werden.
Ja, das stimmt. Nee, das muss schnell gehen. Du hast es geschafft, dass sich zwei Kinder in der Kunst des Rechnens und Subtrahierens üben und einen Fünf-Euro-Schein teilen. Ja, wie so ein Mathe-Heiliger im Prinzip, der den Leuten das Rechnen und Teilen beibringt. Ich habe einen Fünfer gegeben, den ich gefunden habe, wenn ich mein eigenes Geld habe,
als ich ihn morgens gefunden habe, habe ich den abends gegeben,
wurde angesungen und
Hast du das Gefühl, es hat sich gelohnt?
Also hast du karma-mäßig jetzt dafür schon was zurückbekommen
für diese fünf Euro oder
wartest du noch
auf den Cashout, auf den Jackpot?
Karma-mäßig ist es ja in etwa ausgeglichen,
weil ich, wie gesagt, den Fünfer,
das war nicht aus meiner eigenen Tasche bezahlt,
sondern der lag morgens rum.
Moment, ich dachte, karma funktioniert
Mit anderen Karma-mäßig ist es ja in etwa ausgeglichen, weil ich, wie gesagt, den Fünfer, das war nicht aus meiner eigenen Tasche bezahlt habe, sondern der lag morgens rum. Moment, ich dachte, Karma funktioniert andersrum. Man macht erst was Gutes und kriegt dann was Gutes zurück, nicht man kriegt erst was geschenkt und muss das dann mit einem zukünftigen Negativereignis. Es war so eine Tenet-Reihenfolge der Dinge, die alle verwirrt hat, mich eingeschlossen. Armack, das falschrum kam. Also ich habe eine Hooded figure gesehen, eine Kapuze gestalt, die vor mir, die aussah wie ich, meine Sachen trug, ich habe es immer nicht genau erkannt, hat den Fünfer morgens hingelegt. Ich bin, hat den Fünfer aufgenommen, dann wurde abends Sankt Martin, Sankt Martin gesungen, ich gehe mit meiner Laterne, ich habe den Kindern einen Fünfer gegeben, habe denen dadurch Sankt Martins mässig gezeigt, wie man teilt und auf dem Rückweg bin ich an einer Zeitmaschine vorbeigekommen und habe gemerkt, ach, ich habe mir selber den Fünfer hingelegt. Jetzt habe ich aber, ich war dasselbe heute Morgen. Jetzt muss ich mir den Mantel anziehen, um nicht erkannt zu werden von Vergangenheit, Stefan. Richtig, aber keinen Fünfer mehr, den habe ich hier gerade gegeben. Jetzt ist dieses Problem, kann man in Zeitreisen Dinge aus dem Nichts... Nein, da muss ich zur Bank gehen und ganz plakativ fünf Euro abheben, bin dann in die Zeitmaschine gegangen, dann morgens...
Du hast nur fünf Euro abgehoben oder hast du direkt 85 oder so abgehoben oder wirklich nur fünf, den Mindestabhebbetrag?
25.
Du bist 25?
Weil da weiß ich, ich habe noch ein Zwanziger über und der Fünfer ist auf jeden Fall dabei, weil es gibt keine Konfiguration, wo der Fünfer dann fehlen kann. Das stimmt. Weil 25 Euro ist der Fünfer immer dabei. Früher gab es den 25-Euro-Schein, der wurde dann aus dem Verkehr gezogen. Ja, der wurde dann zusammen mit dem 23-Euro-Schein aus dem Verkehr gezogen. Sehr selten. Weil dann hat die ECW gesagt, das war eine sehr klare Pressemitteilung, sorry, wir sind Vollidioten, 23, ich weiß nicht, wie wir das eingebrockt haben. Warum wir 20, 23, 25 und dann erst wieder 50 gemacht haben, da waren wir völlig durch, stick is dick is sorry. Dick is sorry. Und seitdem haben die nichts mehr falsch gemacht, zum Glück. Es lohnt sich doch manchmal auch Fehler einzugestehen, daran kann man lernen. Also bin dann in die Zeitmaschine gestiegen und hab mir selber die fünf Euro vor die Füsse gelegt. Und da habe ich mich geärgert. Aber warum wusstest du das später dann nicht, dass du das schon gemacht hast? Wann? Dass du das in der Vergangenheit schon gemacht hast. Nee, man muss sich das vorstellen wie ein Loop. Und man kommt ja quasi, man geht ja neutral in diesen Loop rein. Wir haben es ja mit Harry Potter 3 zu tun. Also man geht ja neutral in diesen Loop. Sankt Stefan, wir hatten uns eigentlich eher sowas wie eine Predigt vorgestellt oder was Inspirierendes.
Ich habe jetzt aber diese grosse, so funktionierende Zeitreisen in meiner Lore Präsentation vorbereitet hinter mir, so Ted Talk mässig.
Weihrauch wäre da, wir haben alles da.
Nee, zu dem Teilen komme ich ja später, aber das ist eher kurz im Verhältnis.
Teilt, erklärt den dann, wie aufzeilen wir. Aber hier ist diese große Zeit. Nee, aber auf zu weinen. Benni, Mensch, der kleine Benni. Benni wieder am weinen. Der hat sich so gefreut, dass er heute was kriegt. Einen Moment. Wer ist das denn? Hallo, ich bin Robo-Song Stephan aus dem Jahre 2940. Es ist sehr wichtig, dass dieser Junge umgebracht wird. Was, Benny? Benny muss sterben. Benny muss einen furchtbaren Tod sterben. Der Tod muss sogar ein Exempel statuieren. Na gut, dann ist es wohl so. Tschüss, Benni. Ja, tritt weiter auf ihn ein.
Tja, und das ist so, so kann man das sagen. Es war eine merkwürdige Geschichte, aber vielen Dank für die ganzen tollen Sankt-Stefan-Songs.
Wir haben tatsächlich einige bekommen und ich würde sagen, wir machen gleich weiter mit der Hymne von Anna. Der heilige Stefan hatte eine Schulterwunde, kümmert sich dennoch um einen Tod, kein Namen Wunder. Mit ihm zog Stefan durch das Land, als er einen Goldbeutel fand, singende arme Waisenkinder warten ihn und kamen. Der heilige Stefan sagte, ihr könnt den ganzen Goldbeutel haben, die Kinder freuten sich, doch schnell entstand, Zwischen den armen Kindern ein schlimmer Zahn, so viel Gold, doch wer von uns bekommt es dann?
Mit grosser Weisheit half der heilige Stefan, der heilige Stefan lehrte sie zu teilen des Gold, Die Kinder versöhnten sich, so wie es sein soll,
weg Stefan mit seinem grossen Held. Die Kinder versöhnten sich, so wie es sein soll.
Ein Stefan mit seinem grossen Herz, ein Stefan mit seinem grossen Herz, ein Stefan mit seinem grossen Herz, erklärt den Menschen es teilenswert. Jesus, okay, vielen Dank an Anna, die die ganze Geschichte nochmal zusammengefasst hat in musikalischer Form. Und sich aufs Wesentliche beschränkt hat. Ja, also da muss man auch sagen, da wurde sich auf den Kern der Geschichte konzentriert. Es wurde nicht in excruciating detail alles erzählt, was ich erzählt habe, sondern kurz und knackig muss auf eine Hostie passen, so gehört sich das. Vielen, vielen Dank, Anna. Vielleicht wirst du auch heilig gesprochen, für die massgerechte Verehrung von Sankt Stephan. Für die überbordende Verehrung von Sankt Stephan. Ich habe noch einen Song gefunden von Paul Schnaule, diesmal nur in geschriebener Form in unserem Reddit sehr zu empfehlen. Reddit.com slash, ich glaube, r slash das Podcast-Ufo, da könnt ihr alles... Der Tempel quasi. Das ist der Tempel. So, da hat er etwas ganz Tolles geschrieben. Er schreibt, mangels musikalischer Fähigkeiten hier nur ein Textvorschlag für das Sankt-Stefan-Lied. Vielleicht kann da ja jemand anderes aus der Community, der vielleicht keine Texte schreiben kann, sondern nur Musik. Sehr gut. Der sich aufregt. Du verbindest die Leute. Zur Melodie von Sankt Martin, Ritt durch Schnee und Wind. Gut, das denken wir uns jetzt mal weg. Fünfer diesen Kleinen. Die Kinder, die Kinder, die Kinder strahlten voller Glück, doch stritten ums Papier ne Stück. So ging Sankt Stephan zu ihnen hin und sprach zu jenem lieben Kind. Ihr Kindlein, ihr Kindlein, ihr Kindlein denkt an Martins Geschichte. Du, die mehr hat, musst geizen nicht. Gib du die Münzen, du den Schein und keiner muss mehr traurig sein. Das ist unglaublich gut. Die Sprache ist Lehm in seinen Händen. Die Sprache ist Lehm in seinen... Die Sprache wehrt sich nicht. Niemand, also die Sprache kann sich leider nicht wehren gegen das, was hier von Paul angerichtet wird. Paul hat mit großem Hammer, also großem Werkzeug
das Marmorstück der Sprache kaputtgeschlagen.
Richtig.
Sprache wehrt sich gar nicht.
Null. Kein Widerstand, lässt alles mit sich machen.
Sprache hat sich auf dem Boden ergeben,
Hände und Extremitäten weit von sich gestreckt.
War Paul ausgeliefert, aber ich finde,
Paul hat das toll gemacht, also vielen, vielen Dank. und vor allem sich aufs Wesentliche beschränkt. Ja, was willst du denn den Tag vielleicht noch mal festlegen, damit wir das nächste Jahr gebührend feiern können, das wird jetzt neben, war es am Sankt-Martins-Tag, ne, meintest du die Geschichte, weil da die Kinder gesungen haben für dich? Nein, nein, nein, das Problem ist, an verschiedenen Tagen werden diese Sachen, ich meine, es war am 8. November, kann das sein? Und das ist das auch Sankt Martins Tag, weil warum haben die Mädchen sonst für dich gesungen? Ich glaube, es werden verschiedene Tage Laternenumzüge gemacht, weil ich habe an so vielen Tagen Sankt Martin erlebt dieses Jahr, Aber ein paar Tage darauf war ich in Berlin. Und da ging plötzlich abends ein Riesen-Sankt-Martins-Umzug,
zog durch die Strasse, viele Kinder am Singen und war dann im Kino abends. Und dann kam ich aus dem Kino raus, wo dann so Jugendliche auf dem Vorplatz Bier getrunken haben, ganz viele. Und die hatten so eine gelöste Stimmung, da lief auch irgendwie so ein Hip-Hop-Song, so coole Jugendliche halt. Irgendwann war der Song aus und dann hat einer angefangen zu singen, Sankt Martin, Sankt Martin und alle Jugendlichen, und das war wirklich sehr süss, also haben angefangen dann Sankt Martin zu singen, weil den ganzen Tag halt die Sankt Martins Umzüge waren, alle irgendwie noch so einen Ohrwurm haben und abends haben dann sogar die Jugendlichen dann noch Sankt Martin, da oben strahlen die Sterne, unten leuchten wir gesungen, mit Alkoholaugen haben sie gesungen, unten strahlen wir, fand ich sehr lustig. Von daher habe ich das da erlebt, also dieses Jahr war wirklich Sankt Martin omnipräsent. Ich glaube, der Sankt-Martins-Tag ist der elfte gewesen dieses Jahr. Dann haben wir doch den achten Elften jetzt als S jetzt als Sankt-Stephanstag, wo ihr auch gerne Geld teilen könnt mit anderen Leuten. Mit Stefan. Nein, nein, nein, andere Leute zum Geld teilen auffordert. Das ist die eigentliche Leistung. Man-Splaining der Tag. Genau. Anderen vorschreiben, wie sie wohltätig zu sein haben. Das ist der Sankt-Stephanstag. Anderen vorschreiben, wie sie zu teilen haben, was sie an Geld abgeben können und so.
Also im Prinzip dieses Wortergreifen, wenn es darum geht, wie man eine Rechnung splittet am Tisch oder sowas. Also sehr mansplaining wirklich der Tag. Aber wenn diese Kinder jetzt in einer grossen Horde unterwegs sind mit Laternen, wo, also erstens, wer organisiert so einen Umzug und wo endet der? Weil normalerweise endet ein Umzug ja immer an dem Punkt, wo man hin will, so dann irgendwo am Reichstag, wo man dann protestieren will oder so. Wo endet der Sankt-Martins-Umzug? Also irgendwann muss sich da überlegt haben, okay, wir fangen hier an und dann enden wir meistens da, wo man aufgehört hat, oder nicht? Ist das ein Kreis, oder wie? Bei mir war es ein Kreis, bei mir damals, ich war im Kindergarten, bei mir in Südkamen, wir sind vom Kindergarten gestartet, es ritten Pferde mit, also eins, es ritt und dann war da halt so eine Blechkapelle dabei, das war auch immer cool und die Väter wurden mit Glühwein und Warnwesten in die Hand gedrückt, an verschiedenen Strassenkreuzungen geparkt. Die haben dann die Strasse gesperrt, haben die geliebt natürlich, dann so diese Machtausübung mit dieser Warnweste. Jede Form von Uniform tut gut. Tut gut und dann hat so ein Glühwein in der Hand, also dann wirklich die letzten Streckenpostenväter, an denen man vorbeikam, alle Lampen an, also mehr Lampen als die Leute in dem Lüchterumzug. Und dann ist man, glaube ich, wieder zum Kindergarten gekommen, wo dann Sankt Martin sein Schwert gezückt hat, dann seinen Mantel durchgeschnitten hat, was nicht durchgeschnitten hat, weil es nicht geht. Dann wurde ein Prop halber Mantel aus der Tasche gezaubert. Es war mehr ein Kunststück, so ein Zauberkunststück. Gabriele, wir können nicht jedes Jahr einen neuen Mantel zerschneiden, so dick habe ich es auch nicht. Carmenisch ist sehr schwer zu treffen, man muss da wirklich präzise, manchmal auch Anlauf nehmen. Kann man auch nicht. Kann man auch nicht. Ja, die Melodie ist entscheidend. Wir wollen immer Wohltätiges tun und dazu gehört natürlich auch eine gewisse Verantwortung zu tragen dafür, was wir im Podcast sagen und erzählen. Wir sind im Moderationsmodus, wo gehen wir hin? Müssen wir sagen. Du gehst aber mit grossen Schritten in Richtung irgendwas hin. Nein, wir wollen auch zum Jahresende noch was Gutes tun. Und da gehört es natürlich auch dazu, sich um unsere Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer zu kümmern. So, und jetzt passt auf, denn... Ich bin immer so lost. Mir wurde etwas zugeschickt, wo ich dachte, nein, stopp, hier müssen wir eingreifen.
Das ist ein Punkt, da geht es zu weit, da hat unser Podcast vielleicht Negatives erreicht, wo wir Positives erreichen wollten.
Und zwar titelt heute die österreichische Journalismushochburg, titelt Abzocke.
Heiss die Zeitung so?
Nein, die Zeitung heisst heute und die titelt Abzocke, Betrüger gaben sich als Christina Stürmer aus. So, und jetzt müssen wir eine Warnung aussprechen. Wir wissen, wir haben einige Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer zu Christina Stürmer Fans gemacht, die sich vielleicht freuen würden, wenn sich Frau Stürmer bei Ihnen meldet. Vielleicht versteht ihr nicht, was sie sagt. Vielleicht müsst ihr erst ein bisschen nachdenken darüber, was sie euch schreibt. Aber es kann ja sein, dass sie euch angeschrieben hat. Und so, ein Salzburger dachte, mit der Sängerin Christina Stürmer zu chatten. Dabei waren es Betrüger, die ihm so 50.000 Euro entlockten. Okay? Das heißt aber, Christina Stürmer, wenn du uns hörst, wenn sie uns hören, sie haben die Macht, Leuten 50.000 Euro zu entlocken. Auch das, es ist dann glaube ich nicht mal illegal. Wenn ich 50.000 Euro ergaunern will, wäre nicht meine erste Masche, an die ich denken würde, mich als Christina Stürmer auszugeben. Eine, muss man sagen, fast vergessene Künstlerin. In gewissen Kreisen, im Mainstream vergessen, in kleinen Grazer- hochgehalten. In Grazer Kreisen. In kleinen Grazer Kreisen noch graziös hochgehalten. Im Mai 2021 ploppte auf dem Handy eines 48-jährigen Salzburgers die Info-Nachricht von Christina Stürmer auf. Der Mann ist ein großer Fan der oberösterreichischen Sängerin und war ausser sich vor Freude darüber, dass sie mit ihm vermeintlich über soziale Medien Kontakt aufgenommen hatte. So, also, wir warnen vor Betrügern, die sich als Christina Stürmer ausgeben. Passt bitte auf, es kann immer sein. Ich meine, das macht Stefan Tietze auch, er schreibt manchmal willkürliche Leute auf Social Media an, dafür sie sich freuen. Das kennt man ja, dass prominente Menschen einen manchmal anschreiben. Genau, einfach mal so, Nachricht von Stefan Tietze. Nachricht von Freddie Mercury, das stelle ich nicht in Frage. Freue ich mich? Made my day. Die geben ja was zurück, ja, gerade wenn man ein grosser Fan ist, dann geben sie was zurück. Und deswegen bitte aufpassen, es kann schon sein, dass Stefan Tietze euch schreibt, aber seid vorsichtig, wenn das erste Mal Geld fliessen soll, dann würde ich aufpassen. Das heißt aber, seine Liebe an Christina Stürmer war so grenzenlos, naja, wir wissen nicht, wo die Grenze war, vielleicht war die Grenze bei um ne tausend, aber zumindest grenzenlos im Sinne von, sie fragt dann irgendwann wahrscheinlich relativ früh und ungeschickt nach sehr viel Geld. Du bist das Geld, ich geb dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht. Und er so, Moment, ich soll dir Geld schicken? Okay, hier hast du 50.000, reichen 50.000? Vielleicht wollte es die Betrüger gar nicht, es war nur ein bisschen missverständlich formuliert. Wahrscheinlich, aber gut, okay, das heißt, bei welchem Prominenten würdest du, wenn er oder sie dich um 50.000 Euro bittet, dein Portemonnaie zurückgegeben? Ja, natürlich. Bei welchem Prominenten? Dua Lipa. Wenn Dua Lipa dich um 50... Ja, da werde ich schwach. Vor allem würde man ja, aber lustig, weil bei Dua Lipa würde man nicht denken, dass die gerade 50.000 Euro auch angewiesen ist. Es kommt ja immer auf die Geschichte an. Es gibt ja oft so, mein Konto ist eingefroren, ich bin in einem Land. Und da hieß es nämlich, im Laufe der Zeit wurde die Beziehung immer enger zwischen Stürmer und dem Salzburger. Schließlich schrieb die vermeintliche Sängerin dem Salzburger, sie werde sich von ihrem Lebensgefährten trennen und mit ihm eine Beziehung eingeben. Dann schlugen die Betrüger zu. Stürmer hatte eine Firma beauftragt, die Pakete mit Geld und Goldbarren ausliefere. Was, was, was, was? Stürmer hatte eine Firma beauftragt, die, also die Aufgabe der Firma ist es, Geld und Goldbarren auszuliefern, die Versandkosten könne sie allerdings nicht zahlen. Sie habe ein gemeinsames Konto mit ihrem Mann, der nichts davon wissen dürfe. Also hier, natürlich, es wird eine Notlage suggeriert und da will natürlich der gute Fan
aushelfen, dass endlich
das Gold und das Geld auch
geliefert werden kann. Es ist
da, aber es fehlt das
Porto-Geld, um das
Gold zu bewegen.
Ich hab Geld. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Du bist das Geld.
Doch die Geldlieferung ist teurer als das Geld, was ich versetze. Aber das, warum sind wir jetzt in so einem wilden Westenartigen Modus mit, es werden Goldbarren transportiert. Wir müssen die Postkutsche aufhalten. Naja, also die Bedenken hast du ja auch geäußert, eine Christina Stürmer, die hat doch Gold. Und da greifen die Betrüger...
Nicht, das wären Rechtschreibfehler.
Nein, nein, nein. Und da greift die
Betrügerbande natürlich direkt voraus und sagt,
natürlich habe ich Gold.
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Das Problem ist, ich kann das Gold nicht bewegen,
weil je mehr Gold man hat,
desto teurer wird es natürlich auch, das Gold zu bewegen.
Also, gib mir Geld, ich kann
damit nicht mein Gold transportieren können aus Little Forest zu Red Herring.
Ich meine, stell dir vor, wie viel Gold man mit 50.000 Euro transportieren kann.
Also der Wert des Transportguts muss ja um ein Vielfaches darüber liegen.
Goldbarren sind halt super, super schwer. Ja, also man braucht mehr Geld, um sie zu bewegen, als dass sie wert sind. Nee, nein, das glaube ich schon auch nicht. Aber ich glaube, mit 50.000 Euro kannst du schon richtig viel Geld. Aber hat sie denn jemals, das ist halt eine merkwürdige Geschichte. Ja, und okay, aber Vertrauen auch in Christina Stürmer ist ja immens. Ich meine, die haben sich niemals getroffen, und er war komplett davon überzeugt von der Geschichte, dass sie ihren Mann verlässt, für diese random Nummer, die sie geschrieben hat. Hat sie denn, hat sie niemals gesagt, wie sie auf ihn gekommen ist? Nee, steht die nicht drin. Also, ich glaube, das ist... Aber die Betrüger, die Metagsgeschichte, die Betrüger haben gewusst, wer großer Fan ist, wahrscheinlich durch so ein Newsletter.
Davon gehe ich aus, Social Media, Abos und gucken die Aktivität der Profile an, Teil von vielen Fangruppen oder was auch immer. Mal an, es ist trotzdem nicht so trivial, auf die Handynummer zu kommen dann. Okay, aber das kriegt man wahrscheinlich hin. Handy wird nicht gesagt, es wurde gesagt, über Social Media wurde Kontakt aufgenommen, könnte das auch Instagram sein oder so. Gut, das machst du noch dubioser, er hat nicht mal die Handynummer gehabt. Ich meine, Christina Stürmer könnte mindestens die Handynummer rausfinden von ihren Fans, also das ist schon klar. Ich glaube, das Ganze kann man gut verfilmen, auf verschiedenen Perspektiven, natürlich einmal die Betrüger, dann das Opfer und ich würde aber auch immer zwischenschneiden Christina Stürmer, die nichts damit zu tun hat, nichts davon weiß, aber die man auch immer mal so als B B-Plot nebenschneidet. Die man gefühlt nicht weiss, dass die Kamera neben mir steht. Wie man so Apple-Day-Kram macht, wo man sich immer nur gefragt hat, hat er den Film unnötig lang gemacht, der ging am Ende dann dreieinhalb Stunden. Nee, damit der Zuschauer versteht, dass es nicht die echte Christina Stürmer ist, die hier schreibt. Das versteht man schon, weil zwei Männer das machen. Ja, aber der Zuschauer könnte ja immer noch denken, dass es auf dem Weg sozusagen, dass es nicht die echte Christina Stürmer ist, die hier schreibt. Das versteht man schon, weil zwei Männer das machen. Ja, aber der Zuschauer könnte ja immer noch denken, dass es auf dem Weg, dass es im Auftrag von Christina Stürmer stattfindet. Nee, vertrau mir da mal. Du kannst dir diese Christina-Stürmer-Story dann wirklich sparen, obwohl das Double, was ihr gefunden habt, wirklich toll ist. Wirklich genau. Und dann siehst du ja Christina Stürmer, wie sie ihre Goldbarren streichelt, und du siehst, ah, okay, das ist nicht sie. Sie hat kein Problem mit ihrem Mann, das ist eine glückliche Beziehung, man zeigt das. Du bist das Benzin, doch mein Auto steht im Stau gefangen und der Mann so, okay, ich dich auch, vielleicht. So, und man sieht einfach eine herrliche Beziehung und der Zuscht, dass es nicht die ... Nee, es verwirrt eher. Man denkt nämlich irgendwann an einem Punkt, denkt man, ah, sie erpresst die wirklich, weil sie halt dann tatsächlich diese Goldbarren hat. Wo ich überhaupt nicht so viele habe. Und ich dachte eher, okay, Goldbarren, verarsche. Aber dann sieht man Christina Stürmer mit diesen Goldbarren. Dann ist es eine schlechte Schauspielerin, die diese merkwürdigen Texte zu ihrem Mann sagt, wo man sagt, vielleicht lieben die sich doch nicht mehr. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Die Tatsache, dass sie ihn als Gift bezeichnet, zeigt, wie abhängig sie von ihm ist. Das versteht man schon, da will ich mir keine Sorgen machen. Aber vielleicht kann man sie ja sowas sagen lassen wie, ich würde meine Fans nie erpressen. Ich würde nie Geld von meinen Fans nehmen. Vielleicht kann man das unterbringen im normalen Dialog. Du bist jetzt hier, hast mich eingeladen zum Test-Screening und musst auch, finde ich, anhören, was ich zu sagen habe. Wenn du fragst, habt ihr Logiklücken entdeckt? Ich meine, das war deine erste Frage, nicht wie durch den Film gefallen, sondern wo habt ihr Logiklücken entdeckt? Mit einem roten Kopf, als hättest du Angst davor, dass Leute Logiklücken entdecken, als wäre das die grösste Angst. Ich habe das gesagt und jetzt lässt du mich irgendwie nicht aus nicht ausreden. Nee, aber du sagst, ich soll ein Drittel des Films rausschneiden. Also das ist ja auch kein Feedback. Ja, ist ja auch dreieinhalb Stunden lang, ist ja nicht so schlimm. Ja, aber das ist doch kein Feedback, einfach zu sagen, schneid fast die Hälfte raus. Nur die verwirrenden Christina-Stürmer-Elemente, wo man sie beim Duschen sieht und so. Ja, beim Autofahren. So, die denkt ja auch immer, sie wäre allein, das ist mega creepy. Ja, aber dass sie den Tisch aufbaut, zusammen mit ihrem Mann, zeigt ja, wie gut die sich verstehen. Die schreien sich an. Ja, aber nicht so viel wie normal. Nicht so viel wie normal. Sie sagt 90 Grad, meine andere Richtung. Das ist doch egal, wie rum es in der Anleitung ist, das kann man doch auch andersrum lesen und dann auf den Kopf bauen. Ja, es wirkt eher eine passiv-aggressive, furchtbar toxische Beziehung. Nein, aber es ist nicht so viel Streit wie normal. Oder? Ich war nämlich mal wirklich bei so einem Test-Screening, wo jemand ... Auch mit Feedback danach. Genau. Das Geile ist halt, du siehst einen Film in einem richtigen Kino, so Abschlussfilm von so einer Kunsthochschule, und siehst dann einen Film, die natürlich dann Kunststudenten schlecht sind, ich sag's einfach mal.
Aber sagen wir mal, da ist sehr viel Kopf drin, also sehr verkopfte Filme. Ja.
Und dann guckt man so einen Film und hat sehr viele Fragezeichen und am Ende kommt dann
ein Regisseur, Team, was auch immer, Regisseurin auf die Bühne und stellt Fragen, was alles
angekommen ist.
Und ich habe mich nicht mal getraut, Fragen zu stellen, weil ich dachte, vielleicht offenbaren die jetzt. Aber sie stellt die Frage, sie sagt, kam der kapitalismuskritische Unterton rüber und der ganze Raum schüttelt den Kopf. Schüttelt den Kopf und hält so ein Nein-Schild hoch. Ja, okay, da müssen wir noch mal im Schlitten.
Nee, aber es ist eher so, ähm, nee, genau, also so habt ihr Fragen. Ja. Und dann gab es, gibt es natürlich diesen einen vorlauten Studenten, der dann ein paar Fragen stellt. Ehrlich gesagt alle Fragen, die ich mir auch gestellt habe, so, was hat der Erzähler zu bedeuten, wo kommt der her, war er jetzt der Typ, der am Anfang da mal kurz aufgetaucht ist oder nicht? Nee, das war beides mein Freund, der leider die Hauptrolle und den Antagonisten gleichzeitig spielen musste. Das hat nichts damit zu bedeuten. Und dann war das so ein Frage-Antwort-Spiel zwischen diesem einen Studenten, der sich getraut hat, was alle gedacht haben, who the fuck, war dieser Erzähler, und dann gab es so ein Antwort-Spiel, bis am Ende der Regisseur auch gelacht hat und gemerkt hat, ja, wir müssen nochmal einen Schnitt. Und das ist natürlich total geil, naja, naja, naja, dafür sind dann so Test-Screenings ja da, ist ja okay, aber ich musste so sehr lachen, weil das will ich nach jedem Film. Nach jedem Film möchte ich so ein Q&A mit den Machern haben, wo ich dann noch ein paar Fragen stelle und dann vielleicht verändern kann, dass der Film nochmal so gezeigt wird. Ich finde das aber ein gutes Konzept, diese Idee des Sprechers, Klassensprecher, dass sich einer hervortut als ich kann sprechen und wenn du eine Frage hast, schreibst du dir auf dem Zettel und gibst ihm die, den Zettel, damit er die Frage in deinem Namen stellt. Und Stefan hat übrigens auch noch eine Frage, weil ich glaube, so könnte man viel mehr Input generieren, wenn die Leute nicht selber reden müssten, sondern wenn man einfach in Situationen einfach einen Sprecher deklariert und sagt, du sprichst für die Gruppe und jeder aus der Gruppe kann den dann als Sprachrohr benutzen. Macht man doch eigentlich, oder nicht? Ist das so ein natürliches Auswahlverfahren, oder nicht? Jede Gruppe hat einen kleinen Sprecher. Ja. Oh, nee, verschaffst du erst mal Zeit beim Antworten. Ui, ui, ui. Schauen Sie, die Frage war doch, haben alle Gruppen einen Sprecher? Und jetzt möchte ich Sie mal dazu einladen, nachzudenken, was das überhaupt bedeutet.
Okay, Sie haben jetzt eine Minute schon rausgeholt. Schauen Sie, die Sache ist doch die, Gruppen sind eine Zusammenstellung von Menschen, verschiedensten Menschen.
Da können Frauen mit dabei sein, Männer oder irgendwas dazwischen oder ausserhalb. Das ist ja ein Spektrum. Weird wie identitätspolitisch, aber okay. Das ist ja ein Spektrum. Das ist ja, da gibt es ja verschiedene Hintergründe, Herkunftsländer, Gruppen von Menschen können ja in Belieb... Das müssen Sie mich jetzt bitte auch zu Ende erklären lassen. Wenn Sie mir eine Frage stellen, dann müssen Sie auch hören, was ich zu sagen habe, auch wenn Ihnen die Antwort nicht gefällt. Sie gucken so angestrengt, als ob Sie nachdenken müssten die ganze Zeit, was die Antwort ist. Es ist so leicht über die... Gut, da muss ich jetzt nochmal von vorne anfangen. Gruppen sind letzten Endes, wenn man drüber nachdenkt, nur eine Ansammlung von Menschen. Von verschiedenen Menschen. Punkt. Kommt jetzt noch was? Wenn Sie mich ausreden lassen würden. Weil, das ist nämlich so geil, denkst du dir manchmal nicht, jetzt nochmal in die Schule. Mit diesen Skills, mit diesen, ich verschaffe mir Zeit, um nachzudenken. Bis zur Klingel, einfach immer auf die Uhr schielen, bis zur Klingel. Noch 20 Minuten. Und so, ja genau, wenn noch eine Viertelstunde und der Lehrer stellt dir eine Frage, you're fine, du kriegst die Zeit rum, bist du antwortet. Ist doch kein Problem. Ist doch gar kein Problem. Mit so einem Wissen wäre das viel entspannter jetzt die Schulzeit. Aber du bist ein ehrlicher Feedback-Typ, meinst du dann? Also wenn ich dir jetzt meinen Film ... Ja, doch dann ja. Bei dir würde ich ehrlich Feedback sagen, dass gar niemand verstehen kann. Also wenn ich dich einladen würde zu einem Screening von meinem Film, dann ... Wir hatten das Thema schon häufiger, aber ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass ich mir auch nicht so traue, bei meinem Urteil davon, den Film jetzt richtig verstanden zu haben oder nicht. Ja, das ist das Problem, ja, ich verstehe. Also dann so, klar, wenn ich den nochmal sehe oder konzentriert oder alleine und dann mache ich mir Notes und so, dann easy. Aber nach einem Mal gucken im Kino, wenn ich die ganze Zeit darüber nachdenke, wann die Person links von mir das Popcorn jetzt aufgegessen hat und so mich aufregert, dass jemand quatscht. Ich habe zu viel ADHS im Kino, nach einem einzigen Mal gucken, mir zuzutrauen, Feedback zu geben, was dir helfen soll. Ja, ich schaue gerade die dritte Staffel Dead to Me, Dead to Me, Dead to Me, Dead to Me, Dead to Me, Dead to Me. Und ich habe vergessen, was in den ersten beiden Staffeln passiert. Ja, ja. Und die befassen sich in der Serie mit Problemen, die ich nicht verstehe. Die haben Geheimnisse, die sie verheimlichen, dann reden die mit dem Polizisten und dann so, oh, guckt die nervös und ich weiß nicht, was sie verheimlichen. Das heißt, eine Story, wo du die ersten beiden Staffeln vergessen hast, wo es um Probleme geht, die du nicht verstehst, reden Menschen, die du nicht kennst, über Dinge, die du nicht kennst? In der Serie geht es um Geheimnisse.
Figuren haben Geheimnisse und wer weiß, wessen Geheimnis und wie geht er damit um?
Normalerweise ist die Idee, dass der Zuschauer die Geheimnisse kennt.
Ich kenne sie nicht.
Ich bin genauso ahnungslos wie der Polizist, der Fragen steht. Dann möchte ich dir eine andere Serie empfehlen.
1899 kam jetzt raus, wo die Idee ist, dass der Zuschauer auch nichts weiß.
Wo Leute Geheimnisse haben, die du nicht kennst. Die sie auch nicht kennen. Die sie irgendwie unterbewusst traumatisch vergessen sind. Die am Ende nicht aufgelöst werden. Also wenn du das gleiche unbefriedigende Ergebnis haben möchtest, nur ohne Nachdenken, dann schau doch lieber. Was ich mag, ist, wenn ich eine Serie schaue und mir ständig denke, komm, liess noch mal auf Wikipedia den Plot noch. Es ist nicht schlimm, das darf man, das ist okay. Es gibt diese blauen Reklambücher, die extra dafür gedruckt werden. Also es sind ja Leute, die das drucken, die dann wissen, Leute kaufen das, weil sie nicht gecheckt haben, was in Hamlet passiert. Das ist völlig normal. Blau ist der Schlüssel. Blau ist immer der Schlüssel. Das ist normal. Guck mal, Heinrich Heine hat wahrscheinlich direkt dann das blaue Buch angefangen zu schreiben, nachdem er fertig war. Und dann hat er das alles rausgehauen. Das ist okay, man darf sekundär Literatur benutzen, dafür ist sie da. Und währenddessen läuft die gesamte Staffel an mir vorbei und ich kriege überhaupt nichts mehr. Okay, ja, ja. Warum guckst du nicht direkt dann bei Wikipedia und liest dann einfach die Handlung durch, anstatt dir die Lebenszeit zu verdäumen? Weil ich mich schlecht fühle. Ich fühle mich wie ein Cheater.
Ich fühle mich, ich habe ein ganz tiefes Gerechtigkeitsbefinden in mir. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe meine Betrügereien schon aufgebraucht. Für dein Leben? Ja, ja. Ich habe als Kind viel betrogen, immer Cheater, immer Missing No, immer bei der Pokémon-Hotline angerufen und nach Hilfe gefragt. Ich war einfach schwach und weich. Du glaubst also, dass du in deiner Kindheit dein ganzes, quasi
den ganzen Fundus, den man als Mensch
im Leben hat, dein ganzes, wenn
Karma in verschiedene Plus und Minus
eingeteilt ist, du hast dein ganzes
Minus eingelöst für Pokémon.
Ja, alle Cheats.
Sims immer mit Cheat, immer alle umgebracht.
Rosebud.
Nicht verstanden, damals, auch heute, nicht ganz. Auch heute nicht. Ist auch, glaube ich, Top 1 meiner Filme, wo ich immer lüge, dass ich die gesehen habe. Ja, bei Warcraft 3, dass ich viel spiele, sind fast alle Cheatcodes aus Matrix. Also da hast du dann There is no Spoon als Cheatcode. Für heutige Spieler wahrscheinlich sehr kryptisch was bedeutet das was bedeutet das was wollten die wachowski-Schwestern uns damit sagen there is no spoon leben in berlin ja ja stimmt hast du ja erzählt dass du dass du dich mit denen eine Mülltonne teilst ich vergesse nicht nein nein ich wohne nicht in Berlin. Also meine Filmidee ist im Grunde die, wir befinden uns in einer dystopischen Zukunft, ja, des Jahre 2380. Stefan hat das gesamte Universum in seiner Kontrolle. Da wollte ich fragen, ob es in der Figur, ob es um mich geht. So, Stefan ist der Diktator der Herrscher. Film geht los, wir befinden uns im Apartment einer jungen Journalistin. Sie tippt auf ihrem Laptop noch schnell den Artikel zu Ende. Zoe Barnes. Ich denke da, erste Wahl Zendaya, zweite Wahl Jennifer Lawrence, dritte Wahl Kate Mara. Und sie tippt auf ihrem Laptop noch den Artikel zu Ende. Man sieht, sie ist gestresst und sie tippt zu Ende und will jetzt eigentlich Feierabend machen. Ihr Hund kommt und beißt in ihre Jogginghose und ungeduldig. Aber süss oder creepy? Der Hund, also. Ein normaler Hund, ich meine, kein Ernst, ein Cyberhund. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Der Hund ist CGI, komplett CGI. Nö. Aber da wir nicht viel Geld haben, ist der sehr schlechte CGI.
Aber der Effekt ist, dass die Zuschauer sich fragen, ach so, das ist ein Hologramm oder das ist auch in deren Welt CGI, aber es ist nicht klar, es könnte auch einfach schlechtes CGI sein und der Zuschauer denkt sich immer, meine Güte, das kann nicht sein, weil der läuft dann auch so durch Tischbeine durch und so und glitscht da so. War jemand so faul? Ja genau und man fragt sich Wie hat das den Final Cut überlebt? Soll das ein echter Hund sein oder nicht? Also das ist noch eine weitere Ebene so. Okay, zurück zum Diktator. Genau und sie tippt den Artikel noch, schickt ihn ab, macht den Laptop zu, setzt sich auf die Couch mit dem Hund. Der Hund sitzt so halb in der Couch und sie schaut Fernsehen und man sieht so, wir haben so Close-Up ihrer Hosentasche, wo so durch die Jogginghose so das Display von ihrem Handy immer wieder angeht. Aber sie merkt es nicht, aber wir merken, da passiert gerade irgendwas im Hintergrund, irgendwas passiert da und wir wissen nicht, was los ist. Und irgendwann die Serie, die sie schaut, da geht es um so Schmuggler, die in der Zukunft sind Kürbisse total viel wert. Und dann irgendwann wird ihr Programm unterbrochen, Newsflash, neue Artikel rausgekommen, und zwar hat sie nicht Stefan geschrieben, sondern Stefan. Sie hat sich verschrieben. Und das geht gar nicht in der Welt. Im Jahre 2380. Das geht überhaupt nicht. Denn Stefan ist sehr eitel und bringt alle mit seinem Laserstrahlaugen um, die ihn irgendwann sehr schlecht dastehen lassen. Man merkt dann auch, das ist keine wirklich freie Zeitung, das ist eher so eine Propagandamaschine von Stefan selber. Sie schreibt Stefan. Ist das eine Metapher auch unser Reddit? Da kommen wir gleich im FAQ dazu. Ich habe noch nie darüber gelöscht. Ich habe noch nie einen Kommentar gelöscht. Wir machen gleich im Anschluss ein FAQ, dann können wir das abtasten. So jetzt denkt sie, oh shit, shit, shit. Und sofort klopfen an ihrer Tür, der Geheimdienst ist da. Und sie denkt sich, fuck, ich muss weg. So, schnappt sich den Rucksack. Hier Stefan Po. Ja, schnappt sich ihren Hund, geht zum Fenster raus. Wir sehen so einen Wolkenkratzer, 500 Stockwerke hoch, super dichtes Stadtzentrum, urban, irgendwie alles dystopisch krass. Sie klettert an der Fassade, Mensch, ihr Haar weht, aber das des Hundes nicht? Naja, beim Hund fragt man sich gar nicht mehr. Die Simulation ist es, oder ist die Idee, also es ist unklar. und dann geht sie in den Untergrund und findet dort
und sie wird dann sozusagen, ich skippe ein bisschen vor,
sie wird dann zu so einer Art Rebellenheldin
alle sagen, oh, du hast es
gewagt, Stefan in Frage zu stellen
und diese Stefan wird so zu einem
Code für Rebellen, also die im
Untergrund, wenn sie von Stefan spricht,
dann merkt man, ah, du bist auch einer
von denen, die sich auflehnen und sie wollte das
aber gar nicht, sie ist gar keine Rebellin, aber dadurch, dass sie mit den Rebellen im Untergrund Kontakt hat, merkt sie erst, wie schlimm die Gesellschaft ist. Das heißt, die Protagonistin ist gar nicht so mutig und cool wie er. Nein, sie wird ins Abenteuer reingeworfen und merkt erst dann. Ja, ein bisschen wie Frodo. Das stimmt. Wie Frodo oder Garfield. Also die Inspiration für die Figur war Garfield. Und Frodo. Und Frodo. Genauer gesagt, Maura Labinki. Aber dazu kommen wir gleich noch. Das alles im Anhang und im Abspann. Und dann steht diese Stefan, steht dann so als Kampfschrei und sie wird dann sozusagen und sie muss dann damit kämpfen, will ich jetzt diese Rebellenanführerin sein oder nicht und stehe ich dafür und so was und dann macht sie und dann merkt Stefan, wir cutten zu Stefan, wie er seine Goldbarren streichelt und wir merken, er kriegt davon auch mit und eigentlich hat er schon den Tötungsbefehl gegeben, muss den aber zurückziehen, weil sie schon so berühmt ist, dass das jetzt ein Märtyrer tot wäre und dann sagt Stefan, ja, du musst ein Pressestatement abgeben, dass das ein Schreibfehler war. Und dann, wir sehen dieses Pressestatement und auf der einen Seite der Geheimdienst von Stefan so, wir bringen dich um, wenn du das falsch machst, auf der anderen Seite die Rebellen, die sagen, das ist deine Chance jetzt. Und die Frage ist, wird sie jetzt den grossen, die verlammende Rede für die Rebellion halten oder wird sie einknicken? Ende!
Okay.
Also mittendrin. Ja, ist ein Cliffhanger.
Na ja, nee, es ist ja nicht mehr ein offenes Ende oder so, es hat einfach mittendrin auf.
Also es ist kein Handlungsstrang des Befriedigungs
zu Ende geführt. Man weiß auch nicht, was
genau diesen Stefan-Charakter, den ich am spannendsten
fand, was der eigentliche
Star des Films für mich, was den antreibt
und so und warum der jetzt so eine Schreckenserschaft hat.
Der ist eitel und arrogant
und böse vor allem. Ja, ein Trauma hat er erlebt, also aus welchem Geist heraus ist er denn so geworden? Also der will nicht, dass Leute ihre Meinung sagen, weil sie ihn sonst kritisieren können. Weil ich würde da jetzt eine andere Figur noch hinzufügen quasi, die Stefan dazu bringt. Weil Stefan war ja, das wird ja eigentlich ziemlich deutlich, wie gesagt, spannende Figur für mich, dass er eigentlich früher mal, da hat er mal das Land gebührend regiert. Und alle hatten Spaß und es war irgendwie ein cooles Land. Ja, vielleicht geht es darum in der Serie, die sie schauen. Vielleicht hat er diesen ehemaligen Partner gehabt oder sowas, der ihn dann sozusagen korrumpiert hat und so. Vielleicht können wir das in der Serie einbauen, so dass die Figuren, diese Kürbisschmuggler dann reden so, oh, früher war alles besser, als noch dieser andere da war, der irgendwie den Stefan so ausgeglichen hat, der irgendwie so eine positive Kraft im Imperium war. Seitdem der weg ist, oder der ist halt so, also die Idee ist, dass er so aufsteigt zu so einer Helden-Engels-Götterfigur und er kommt dann vielleicht in Teil zwei.
Und das kann man dann so nebenbei vielleicht einbauen.
Ja, super, nee, nee, klar.
Findest du gut, hat dir gefallen?
Wie gesagt, also ich könnte mich sehr hineinversetzen in diesen Stefan-Charakter, den ich jetzt gar nicht so schlimm fand.
Schreib das mal auf, also Sie finden den Stefan-Charakter gut.
Ja, ich finde ihn richtig cool. Journalisten fand ich eher nervig und so. Die Hauptfigur war eher nervig. Umgebracht werden. Oh, okay. Habe ich nicht verstanden. Also habe ich nicht verstanden, warum die das nicht gemacht haben. Sie wollen, dass sie direkt am Anfang stirbt, nachdem sie den Artikel veröffentlicht. Ja, genau. Also weil es auch mega gemein und so Stefan, also why, das macht man ja nicht. Also kann man ja, muss schon auch einmal als Journalist, das ist ja auch eine Sorgfaltspflicht, muss man man auch einmal nochmal gegenlesen. Das ist schon auch ziemlich gemein. Sie meinen, der Bösewicht hat Recht und die Protagonistin. Aber es ist ja auch gut. Also ein guter Bösewicht, also böse in Anführungszeichen, habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, aber es ist ja auch gut, wenn der Bösewicht nachvollziehbar handelt. Dann hat man ja einen guten Bösewicht. Gut. Aber war nicht die eigentliche Bösewichtin die Journalistin? Zoe Barnes. Ja, ist ein interessanter Punkt. Kann man auch gegen U-Bahn werfen. Wäre vielleicht guter Tod. Es ist nicht Zoe Barnes. Ja, diese Journalistin, die den Schreckensherrscher auffallt. Nein, aber sie macht es nicht aus eigenem Antrieb raus, sondern es ist ein Fehler, es ist ein Schreibfehler. Der Film heißt The Typo. The Typo? Ja.abhängig von dem furchtbaren Film, den du geplottet hast, finde ich The Typo einen fantastischen Titel für den Film. Ja, und das ist aber auch falsch geschrieben, oder? Ja, natürlich. Wie würde man Typo falsch schreiben? O ist eine Null, das T ist eine umgedrehte drei. Kriegt man schon hin? Können wir aufhören, übrigens bei Logos und so, einen Punkt hinten dran zu setzen oder ein Ausrufezeichen? Oder irgendwie, hört auf mit ... Meinst du McDonalds, dass die jetzt ein Ausrufezeichen hinten dran gefügt haben? Nein, aufhören damit. Ach so. Zum Beispiel bei Job fällt mir das immer negativ auf. Ja. Ausrufezeichen hinten dran. Schrecklich, schrecklich. So viele Marken haben so einen Punkt hinten dran. Okay, stattdessen willst du drei Punkte. Nein, nein, lasst. Dass es dann eher so ein offenes Ende ist. Ja, dann ein Fragezeichen. Job? Ja. Job? Nee. Nee, unsere Marke da hinten, die können sie nicht mehr ausbauen. Ach so, okay. Was hat der auch schon eine Mäntel. Ach so, ich, ach so. Jupp? Ich weiß nicht, mit wem Sie reden. Also, ja, okay, also Fragezeichen hat mich jetzt überzeugt irgendwie, aber mir gefällt das Ausrufezeichen nicht, mir gefällt Satzzeichen, gefallen mir in Logos nicht. Hört auf mit Satzzeichen, das ist uncool. Also auch keine Kommata oder so, das ist nichts für dich. Nein, es gibt diese Marke, die heißt Komma und dann ist am Ende noch ein Komma dran. Weg. Wobei, da macht es auch Sinn, aber weg. Also du sagst auch, was ist mit Pieck, wie heißt der Pieck und Kloppenburg, das und, das kaufmännische und? Oder würdest du es eher durch ein Komma ersetzen? Pieck, Komma, Kloppenburg, Komma, etc. O, Punkt, äh, Punkt. Nämlich nervt nur, weil das war ja damals meine Schülerfirma, damals in der ich war. Jetzt kommt die böse Hintergrundgeschichte, auf die wir gewartet haben. Damals hatten wir den ganzen Markt in unserer Hand. 2011, Leute ohne grafischen Background und irgendwie Markenbildungsskills und sowas. Wir haben damals schon am Ende unseres Firmenlogos einen Punkt gesetzt, weil es irgendwie stylisch aussah.
Wie hieß die Firma?
Möchte ich nicht sagen. Wir haben damals schon das gemacht.
Die Prozesse laufen noch.
Wie hieß die Firma?
Pendant. Lawsuit pending. Möchte ich nicht sagen.
Ich möchte nicht sagen!
Hast du noch Aktien?
Nee.
Oh, da ist ja aber ein reumütiger Blick jetzt drin gewesen.
Das war eine gute Zeit.
Zum falschen Zeitpunkt abgestossen?
Es lief doppelte Buchführung und alles.
Das war genial.
Es war ein grosser Coup. Das war wirklich ein grosser Coup. Ich dachte, meine Kindheit wäre schlimm. Der Wirtschaftsbetrug. Da warst du alles mit Pokémon-Sheets, dich zu einem bösen Menschen. Da habe ich mich mit echtem Betrug strafbar gemacht. Muss man sagen, muss man ganz klar sagen. Aber machen doch alle. Ich meine alle in diesen, ne, es sind dann diese kleinen Schüler mit den grossen Augen und den grossen Bilanzbüchern. Ist doch alles gelogen. Was war das Geschäftsmodell? Ihr gebt euch als Stefanie Heinzmann aus und ruft Leute an oder das? Ne, wir schreiben Mails, wir schreiben Mails als Stefanie Heinzmann, um mit den Fans zu interagieren. Es wäre eigentlich geil, wenn man so eine richtig Evil Corp, so eine ganz böse Schülerfirma gründet. Nee, wir haben ein Hörspiel, also nach außen hin waren wir mega lieb und cool, wir haben ein Hörspiel gemacht gegen den Klimawandel, wohlgemerkt, 2011, 2011, Leute, loilalala. Ach, ihr habt den Klimawandel beendet, ihr war das. Ich habe mich schon gefragt, wer hat da eigentlich mal die Kurve gekriegt damals? Nein, aber wir waren so der Anfang.
Mit uns hat es so angefangen, dass man sich da mal kritisch äussert.
Damals gab es ja dieses große Florentin-Regime, diesen großen Schreckensherrscher.
Oh, das war super.
Florentin.
Das war super.
Und ihr habt Hörspiele gemacht gegen den Klimawandel.
Genau.
Aliens, zwei Aliens kommen auf die Erde, um den Menschen hier zu sagen, dass es so nicht mehr weitergeht. Wie haben die Aliens gesprochen? Wie Menschen. Also die haben sich in Menschen verwandelt oder die haben nur so gesprochen wie Menschen? Das wird nicht erklärt, das wird komplett nicht erklärt. Aber wie gesagt, Kürnheim machen wir am Ende. Okay. Und gibt es diese Hörspiele noch? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe noch eines zu Hause. Und warst du auch Sprecher? Ich war, glaube ich, auch Sprecher, ja. Oh, meinst du nicht, du könntest über die Weihnachtstage da mal was rauskramen? Ja, stimmt. Oh, das ist was für die Club-User. Das ist was für die Clubber. Ah ja, für den Patreon, klar. Die kriegen dann noch ein komplettes Hörspiel. Die kriegen Ausschnitte, weil da ist auch sehr viel Avatar-Musik drin, das weiß ich noch. Hahaha! Das weiß ich noch. Sehr viel Avatar-Musik. Ah, geil. Wie gehypt bist du jetzt auf Avatar 2? Oh, sehr, sehr. Aber das war James Cameron, sämtlich wieder da. Ich habe ja schon Bedenken geäußert, weil das jetzt so lange in Produktion war, habe ich höllische Angst, dass da irgendwie Gangnam Style drin ist oder irgendwie Harlem Shake und so. Und James Cameron dachte, geil, das wird gut zum Release. Und jetzt ist es um fünf Jahre verschoben worden, jetzt checkt das kein Mensch mehr. Angela Merkel-Gags funktionieren nicht mehr. Ich hab richtig Angst vor diesem Film, muss ich sagen. Aber tolles Wasser, oder? Das Wasser sieht toll aus. Das Wasser sieht toll aus. Und ich hab da gar keine Angst vor, dass irgendwelche popkulturellen Referenzen nicht funktionieren. Weil das muss man wirklich Avatar gestehen. Es ist was ganz Eigenes, Weirdes. Es ist so eigenartig auch in seiner Organisation. Es ist so interessant, weil irgendwie, es gibt keine Fans von Avatar, aber es ist trotzdem erfolgreich. Also Avatar 1 war ja richtig erfolgreich, aber irgendwie, es gibt keine Memes, keine Referenzen, keine geflügelten Worte, so wo man sagt, jetzt bei Harry Potter, da hat jeder so ikonische Szenen im Kopf und irgendwie den Avatar-Gedagel oder so. Es gibt diesen Freizeitpark, den niemand kennt, wo man sich dazu entschieden hat, dass diese blauen Navi, das einzig Interessante an Avatar, nicht vorkommen, weil die ja riesengroß sein müssten und das schwierig ist.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt sagen muss, wenn man schon mal im Zirkus war oder im Freizeitpark, da laufen manchmal Leute auf Stelsen rum.
Ja.
Wäre es jetzt so schwer, oder diese Samuel Koch-Kängurus-Schmoll. Sieben-Meilen-Stiefel, ja. Die Sieben-Meilen-Stiefel. Ich meine, dann setzt man halt, das kriegt man doch hin. Ja, ja. Ich verstehe schon, dass es teuer ist und vielleicht ein bisschen ungelenk, aber für diesen Freizeitpark, also na ja, gut, aber das ist ja echt eine weird Entscheidung, einen Avatar-Freizeitpark aufzumachen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie so ein, weiß ich nicht, Pui Pui Molka-Freizeitpark aufzumachen, wo man sich denkt ... So ein Bärenmarke-Bär-Freizeitpark. Gibt's genug Inhalt dafür? Wir haben eine Achterbahn und es liegt in der Liebnis. Ich fänd's so witzig, wenn Aliens auf die Erde kommen und die sehen exakt aus wie die Navi aus Avatar. Und also wie exakt und alle so, James, what the fuck? James, komm! Und James so, keine Ahnung. Also das, glaube ich, würde alles überschatten. James, das kann doch nicht, hör mal, hey, hey, dreh dich mal zu uns bitte. Was ist, wenn das dann unser Untergang ist? Und eingeleitet dadurch, dass wir die nicht ernst nehmen? Weil angenommen, es kommen Aliens auf die Erde, die sehen ganz anders aus, mega weird und so. Und da ist direkt so eine Grundskepsis in uns Menschen. Und diese Skepsis hilft uns dann auch meinetwegen in einem interstelaren Konflikt, weil wir vorsichtig sind. Angenommen, die sehen alle aus wie Chewbacca. Keine Chance, dass es dazu kommt. Ja, stimmt. zu, ich bin auch der Erste, der ein Foto macht, der wenn ein Alien in der Strasse landet bei mir, in einem Kornfeld, in Carmen, in so einem Kornkreis landet, dass ich gar keine Angst habe vor Chewbaccas, lauf da hin und mach ein Selfie mit ihm und nimm den so in den Arm. Und so Tränen laufen mir runter und ich umarme dieses grosse fällige Etwas und dann beißt er mir den Kopf ab. Aber das ist auch wieder ein geiler Film, oder? Also Copyright-technisch schwierig, aber Aliens kommen auf die Erde und die haben die Popkultur verstanden, weil die haben schon über Jahrtausende Das ist der Twist aber erst. Erst sehen die alle aus wie Chewbacca. Genau, sehen alle aus wie Chewbacca und später stellt sich heraus, nein, das sind Gestaltwandler, die einfach schon die Signale der Erde schon seit Jahrtausenden analysieren und die Popkultur analysiert haben. Und die eine erscheinen als Navi, Super Mario, Link, Christina Stürmer. Ich meine, da braucht natürlich eine Menge Unterschriften um den Film, damit der funktioniert, weil dann halt irgendwie am Ende Prinzessin Peach irgendjemandem den Kopf abbeisst oder so, klar, muss man gucken, aber das wäre doch auch cool, dass die halt wissen, wie man, das ist genauso, wie wenn du so eine Kamera in den Dschungel stellst, das aussieht wie so ein kleines Äffchen und die Äffchen merken es nicht, so würde man es doch auch machen, so würden die Aliens doch auch mit uns gehen, so, ja, verkleidet das irgendwie als diese lustigen Figuren da. Aber das würde ja schon auch ein bisschen bedeuten, dass sie schon unter uns fallen. Kann sein, ich trau keinem Maskottchen. Ich trau keinem Maskottchen. Ich trau dem Maskottchen so sehr. Vorsicht. Sharky. Sharky ist mein Lieblingsmaskottchen. Von allen Maskottchen mag ich Sharky am liebsten. Der Kölner Haie-Haie. Hat er Beine? Der hat grosse Beine. Warum hat er Beine? Und Schüchen. Er hat Schüchen an. Als Schlittschuhe oder normale Schuhe? Nee, normale Sneaker. Aber er macht Kunststücke auf dem Eis und macht die Bauchwelle zum Beispiel oder Breakdance. Sharky ist mit das coolste Maschottchen, was es auf der Welt jemals gibt. Wenn jemand was gegen Sharky ist, wenn Aliens als Sharky erscheinen, eat me, eat me alive. Du bist der Erste, der Freiwillige. Das finde ich genial. Glaubst du unter uns beiden schon Aliens? Das ist ein Handaufs Herz. Ja, ich glaube schon, aber halt eher so mikrobisch. Ach so. Dass dir auf so Meteoriten, da war irgendwie so ein kleiner Floh oder so ein kleines Bakterium. Und das ist unter uns und das macht schon was. Aber das checken wir noch nicht, weil ich meine, das ist so im Dschungel, jeden Tag werden neuntausend neue Spinnenarten entdeckt. Jeden Tag. Woher wissen wir, dass die alle schon ... Woher wissen wir das? Das habe ich gelesen. Das war so ein Bild, aber auf dem Bild war Text. Sagen wir drei Spinnenarten. Ich glaube, es ist nur neuntausend. Und woher wissen wir eigentlich, dass die schon immer da waren? Vielleicht sind die einfach neu, also neue Wesen, die aus dem All dazugekommen sind. Die aus dem All herunterploppen auf uns. Vielleicht kommen ständig Aliens und wir denken, oh, neue Maus, neue Ratte, neuer Tukan entdeckt und so. Nein, die sind einfach frisch neu, ganz neu da. Aber diese Biologen, die verstehen sich. Die wollen dann immer ihren Namen überall drauf klatschen und so. Ist eine Wissenschaftleruntergruppe vielleicht wahnsinnig dumm? Weil wir wissen es ja nicht, wir sind ja selber keine Biologen, wir haben die Ausbildung nicht. Und neue Biologen werden ja von alten Biologen ausgebildet, das heißt die Dummheit, die niemand überprüft, wie dumm es ist. Ne, jetzt mal ernst die Frage, glaubst du, eine Wissenschaft hängt massiv hinterher? Ja. So eine, so stimmig vor die Biologen, man kann es ja nicht bewerten, weil wir sind alle keine Biologenen und so und wir sind außerhalb und so, aber die Chemiker machen einen mega Job und sind mega geil und mega weit dafür, wo wir eigentlich stehen, gerade 2022, aber die Biologen hinken mega hinterher, haben gar keinen Plan und mögeln sich so durch. Und haben halt so krass klingende Worte, irgendwie Fotosynthese, warum muss das alles so kompliziert sein, was wollen die verstecken? Weil wenn du dich sicher, also wenn du dich als eigene Branche, wenn du es schaffst, alle einzubeziehen, zu sagen, wir lehnen uns jetzt zurück, wir arbeiten nicht, wir gastieren Money, Money, Money, Money, aber wir arbeiten gar nicht mehr so viel. Ab und zu hauen wir mal irgendwie in Be a lot, Be a lot, Biology Now oder so aus neuen Magazin raus. Ja, lass uns mal so diese Pipetten kaufen und diese flachen Plastikdeckel. Ja. Und da tropfen wir dann was rein. Einfach so ein Stück Käse, Camembert rein. Ja, so Käse oder so Rote Flüssigkeit einfach so. Ja, ja. Ich habe noch ein bisschen Farbe im Kühlschrank. Okay, Joe besorgt die Farbe. Okay. Joanne besorgt die Pipetten. Yes, sir.
Und Marco?
Ich hatte als Kind einen Hamster.
Bring den her. Ich gucke mal, ob ich den noch habe.
Wie lange haben wir einen Hamster? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
2000 Jahre.
Aber wenn ihr so als eigene Gruppe, als Branche es schafft,
sich zurückzuziehen und maximal, weil alle Menschen sind doch faul. Alle Menschen sind faul, niemand will arbeiten, alle hassen Montage, niemand will zur Arbeit gehen. Wenn du dann als einziger in deinem Büro auffällst, als fauler Idiot, fällst du auf. Du bist so ausgeliefert. Ja, und du fällst auch als einziger Fleissiger auf. Natürlich. Und wirst dich anpassen und wirst sagen, ach so, nee, nee, nee. Genau, aber das ist so, wenn du aber alles schaffst zu überreden auf deiner Etage, immer noch ein Problem, weil andere Etagen leisten wir möglicherweise mehr. Wenn du aber als ganze Branche oder Wissenschaftszweig, wie die Biologen. Ey, stell dir den Skandal vor. Aliens waren immer schon unter uns, nur die Biologen haben es nicht gerafft. Haben es vermasselt. Haben es einfach nicht gerafft. Frieder Maus, sorry, für Außenstehende völlig offensichtlich, dass das nichts auf diesem Planeten hier zu tun hat. Die haben nicht mal DNA. Die teilen nichts mit uns, weil sie haben keine DNA. Moment, wie, die haben keine DNA. Was ist denn da drin? Wir können es nicht beschreiben, weil wir haben keine Ahnung. Ich bin neu in diesem... Wie sieht es denn aus, wenn man da reinguckt? Mein Name ist Stefan. Ja, hallo Stefan. Ich habe vor drei Wochen angefangen, Biologie zu studieren und so.
Und die Leute, die es mir erklärt haben, habe ich mir gedacht, das sind Idioten.
Da bin ich mir selber ein bisschen eingelesen.
Und ich habe wirklich nur drei Wochen das zu lernen gebraucht, um zu checken, dass Fledermäuse, das ist die erste Art, die ich untersucht habe, haben keine DNA.
Alle Biologen sind faul, die haben seit Jahren nicht mehr gearbeitet.
I'm just saying, guckt hin, guckt genauer hin. Es sind Aliens. Ja, müssen wir mal überlegen, ob wir das veröffentlichen. Ach, jetzt sind Journalisten auch alle faul. Wie hießen sie nochmal? Stefan. Stefan, ja. Mit A-N, nicht O-N. Oh, gut, dass Sie es sagen. Warum? So weird, das ist ein rechter Fehler. Warum sollte man da hin? Das ist ganz weit weg vom A. Es gibt kaum Buchstaben, die so weit weg sind vom A. Wirklich, schauen wir auf der Tastatur. Das O ist so weit weg vom A. Ja, das stimmt, das ist wahnsinnig weit weg. Warum ist das A und das Ä eigentlich so weit weg, oder? Also haben die sich verstritten? Das ist einfach so, das E ist das A mit O. Es sind wie so Geschwister, die sich so entfremdet haben. Aber es ist ja oft so, wenn man sich ganz ähnlich ist, dann will man möglichst die Unterschiede betonen. So wie wenn du der einzige in der Schule bist, der auch Star Wars Fan ist, dann willst du nicht immer nur mit dem abhängen, damit du nicht nur der Star Wars Typ bist, sondern du musst dann auch noch dich unterscheiden von dem, obwohl du den eigentlich richtig gern magst.
Aber du kannst nicht in jedem Kurs neben ihm sitzen, weil sonst, das sind halt die Star-Wars-Typen so.
Du musst dich halt auch abgrenzen von anderen. Man existiert hier nur durch Differenz. Wenn du genauso bist wie irgendwas anderes, dann verschmilzt man ja so.
Man existiert nur durch Differenz. Und damit entlassen wir euch in dieser Woche. Macht mal einen Unterschied. Ihr existiert nur durch Differenz. Macht was anders als alle anderen. Gerade jetzt bei der Zeit, die jetzt kommt, der Jahreszeit. Spannend. Welche Zeit kommt jetzt? Weihnachten, würde ich nur behaupten. Da ist Existenz durch Differenz relativ schwierig, weil Weihnachten ist ein sehr konformes Fest. Wünschen wir schon einen frohen ersten Advent oder ist das übergekehrt? Der war schon, der war schon, sind wir zu spät. Wenn die Folge rauskommt, ist es fast zweiter Advent. Die Zeit fliegt, ne? Ich dachte es dir. Die Zeit fliegt. Das ist mein Zitat. Die Zeit fliegt, flogen die Zitat ist, ihr existiert nur durch Differenz und die Wahrheit liegt wie immer irgendwo in der Mitte. Vielen, vielen Dank an Sankt Stephan für dieses ausführliche Interview. Wir haben ihn jetzt alle ein bisschen besser kennengelernt. Wir freuen uns alle auf sein zweites Wunder. Auf sein zweites Album. Und ich habe gehört, Sie haben jetzt auch ein Buch geschrieben für den Weihnachtsmarkt. Also ideales Geschenk für alle Unentschlossenen. Fünfer teilen heißt es. N-Fünfer teilen. Erst Strich dann N. Gib ihnen Fünfer. Gib ihnen Strich N-Fünfer. Sprache ergibt sich vor mir. Nichts hat mehr eine Bedeutung. Die Sprache hat keinen Anwalt. Das ist auch ein guter Satz, finde ich gut. Die Sprache hat leider, leider, leider keinen Anwalt. Ja, unsere Sendezeit ist leider um, vielen Dank, Herr Sankt-Tietze. Wenn ihr musikalische Skills habt, dann vertont doch nochmal diesen tollen Text von Paule. Lass uns einfach die gesamte Weihnachtszeit zur Sankt-Stephans-Zeit erklären. Jetzt ist es auch schon egal, jetzt ist auch schon, jetzt ist die Box offen, jetzt ist die Dose offen, wir kriegen sie nicht mehr zu, jetzt müssen wir es auch aufessen, so. Jetzt einfach durch, dann haben wir es hinter uns. Außerdem gefällt mir, dass die Sankt-Stephan-Geschichte, die andere Geschichte, wo ich im Restaurant einen Stern gegeben habe, übertönt. Das ist Geheimnis von Heiligen, dass sie einfach mit ihren Wundern anderes übertönen. Vielen Dank nochmal an Linus und an Anna für diese fantastischen Beiträge.
Haut rein, habt noch eine ganz schöne Woche und wir heben ab den Himmel! I'm a good man! It's a, it's a, it's a, it's a worst part production.